Pro Hamas protesters they shut down the
South 101 freeway through downtown LA
yesterday think we got some video here
so look they just jump on a highway that
is one of the major highways that goes
right through Los Angeles and look at
the cops look at the cops 10 cop cars
right there cops walking by you don't
know if there's ambulances there uh
there were several school buses so
they're basically holding children
hostage someone's trying to get home
from work everyone else out there that
lives somewhere else that hasn't gone
down that road yet you better make sure
that you're elected offici
are going to do the right things related
to this well here's uh some of the angry
drivers watch them removing some of
these Pro Hamas people and I stand with
these
[Applause]
people